what are you doing here today
is this some kind of setup or something
how's it going bro my name is today
we're checking out to Catch a Predator
the primers of this show you've probably
seen it creep goes to underage person's
house Chris Hansen comes in says how can
you do this he says I don't like this
I'm Gonna Leave Chris Hansen goes yeah
you're free to leave psych you're
arrested I've actually never watched the
full episode but that changes today is
this some kind of setup or something
I'm just on my way to the beach I love
that line so much
I'm just on my way to the beach what
what I am in an underage woman's house
what I hate when this happens every time
I go to the beach this happens it could
happen to anyone I swear
he's Michael Willis screen name generic
white male
I ain't lying about that one 50 years
old and he's been chatting online with a
girl who calls herself jolanda and who
says she's 15. he lies to her about his
age typing I'm 30. you probably don't
want me around you I'm cute though build
good
what this is not a funny show I don't
care that he lied that he's 20 years
younger but saying he's cute no get out
of here
get the [ __ ] out of you then he says
we'd have to keep us a secret because of
the age difference younger girls like
you don't come along often I'd want you
again and again I'm confused I thought
he was just going to the beach picture
of his penis to the girl yeah
why you've already censored 95 just
don't show it God damn it it was 15.
and how did you meet her
well of course online you act like I
should know that
well yeah I mean it's a common thing now
no
no
don't group me into this all right yeah
yeah it's a common thing do you know
PewDiePie met his wife online it's not
no before we continue quick word from
sponsor
Ed buy one get one no excuses you are
welcome I expect to thank you you're
welcome gifuo's biggest sale of the year
is bad
I'm gonna explain this slowly because I
know it's really complicated
buying one
[Music]
okay what was it
boy look this is the one marched design
isn't it cute lingonberry the greatest
flavor God has gifted upon this Earth
anyone that doesn't say it's their
favorite flavor is either insane
delusional or just simply should be
killed that might be a little far
actually
did a the new Shaker silver PewDiePie
Shaker will also be available the
science dude that g Fuel and I have
cooked up something special for you guys
I'm beyond excited to introduce to you
PewDiePie limited edition sour Edition
all the G fuel flavors whenever sours
they're the best so obviously the best
of the best sour PewDiePie limited
edition it's delicious I don't think it
was possible to perform better than
Perfection it is included in the buy one
get one so definitely you know get this
one and provide limited edition it is
also a great time to try out different
flavors Mega Man's blue bomber is
delicious I love that one Naruto Pamela
Peach also delicious and why not smell
the ring cream some tears that's it
definitely take advantage of this it's
the biggest sale of the Year by what was
it again buy one get one sorry I feel
like I have to yell sometimes doesn't
mean I don't love you
unless you buy one get one okay then I
remind generic white male that jolanda
told him she was 15. what away
Oscar
give this man all of them what no way
once you get out of prison he can have
an acting career that's for sure I have
the transcript of your conversation with
jolanda
you know what I don't want this cookie
built again
too many cookies you know what fine you
can have the cookie
I don't want it anymore
there's almost like a switch for these
people the first they're like they try
and light a way out of it what
goes I just want to get to the beach
come here just one second sir but
generous is trying to get down won't be
going to the beach today as he heads out
the back he stumbles off the porch right
into the arms of the Fort Myers police
station yeah
I'm just going to the beach quickly take
them down to the ground in Florida where
it's relatively easy to get a permit to
carry a concealed weapon oh God I love
he's clearly not captain or whatever it
is you Americans call it I love how many
cops they have a child could have rested
that man he was not he did not have a
good physique but no let's let's throw
five cops in there these officers aren't
taking any chances so yeah he's done
newer episodes now as well and they're
also pretty funny I know they're not are
they supposed to be funny am I
anyway let's check it out my house is
your house he's coming to meet a boy who
he thinks just turned 13.
I'm sorry what back up 13.
he's supposed to be 13. the Creed comes
in and be like what the hell is this
you look like you're 25. what
it's like those uh teen drama shows the
actors are like [ __ ] 30 and they play
like 14 year olds and you're like what
the what is this they look nothing like
teenagers so where do you want to go
want a water or something he should
probably take a sip because in a moment
he's gonna meet me his name is Jesse
Velez he's 28 years old his scream name
is Jose he's engaged and he's a general
manager at a major sandwich shop chain
well I'm never having sandwich again
he's engaged God damn this is so
disturbing I mean obviously that's not
the most all right
in our sting house in Fairfield
Connecticut more than a dozen hidden
cameras why did they do that to that
bush that's so necessary what he asked
for next will make you sick come live
with me lol you're kidding right no LOL
how are you going to explain a 12 year
old kid living with you I won't no one
won't find out doesn't know it but
there's no kid on the other end of the
smartphone it's really a woman named
Lori it's a weird job to have posing to
be 13 year olds online
right
you've done the thing I told you to do
right 12 14. you hungry yeah
where do you want to go
doesn't matter to me I'm not really
hungry I just ate no no so you want to
stay here
no not really you don't want to stay
here
did you want it what do you want to do
after
hang out you know Netflix seems Seems
like he's kind of suspicious like why
wouldn't he want to stay then doesn't
any weird question but you have your ID
on you I don't have an idea
sorry I'm only 13. see yeah I think he's
suspecting something's up here but if he
says he's 13 and he asks for an ID isn't
that like that's cue to get out but
obviously he doesn't want to but it's
just it doesn't make sense it seems like
he's trying to cover his tracks like oh
yeah I asked him for an ID oh I live
here
me my mommy and my daddy
sir you are you are 25 years old
Velez looks straight at one of our
history
moves into distraction Mode come look at
this this right here this is my dad made
this oh he did yeah
pretty cool wanna come look at it
no
why would I look at a [ __ ] table
realize is that he's being moved into
position for what will be the surprise
of his life what's happening nothing
what was your plan today nothing
actually just to hang out just to hang
out yeah it was a 13 year old boy
who you sent a picture of your private
parts no I did it I did yes
the lion commences what is that reaction
I'm sorry what
who you sent a picture of your private
parts no I did it I did yes
when you
what
oh I can't believe someone would do that
oh wait I did that oh yikes
it's like whoops finger slate no
nothing's really sexual to be honest
with others nothing really
what's this let me see
look how confident he pretends to be oh
my God yeah
it was right yeah
I can't believe what they did
I hate you
look I'm I'm Ewing I had the right to ew
you don't have the right to ear right
now okay God he's acting like people on
Twitter somebody wants to hit that but I
didn't know why because this was just
one big mistake yeah I pretty much yeah
so you had a picture of yourself
yeah we're all gonna laugh about this oh
my God I can't believe it's a picture of
my private part
so crazy
let me know because I would even say
like something afterwards I didn't know
I really sent that to be honest
honestly I know it's for hookups I
really do know that but I don't I'm not
all for that I don't just meet people
randomly and just start having sex with
other people that's not what I do
it's so frustrating trying to listen to
this guy just lies way out of it
God I hate him okay how old are you I'm
actually 27. not true at the time of our
confrontation Velez had just turned 28.
but you see how I don't think that
really is that really meant was that
like a yeah we got him
not true he actually just turned what
the [ __ ] who cares
we got him now not true
he'll go like oh you were trying to date
an 11 year old he's like actually uh
there were 12. I'm like
that's
thank you for this actual experience
actually because uh
it's pretty interesting actually Jesse
thank you for this experience he doesn't
realize he's fine he thinks it's just
some random guy like I've been like
shame on you sir don't do that don't do
it again he's like oh see
he's smiling as he leaves yeah he's
smiling he just dodged a bullet
not quite
oh where's the exit right there
how many people were in there yeah
that's not an exit that's an entrance to
prison beat
Velez was charged with three felonies
but ultimately pleaded guilty to two
attempted risk of an injury to a minor
and enticing a minor by computer plus he
has to register as a sex offender for 10
years that's an end to that I thought it
was forever
there's some older ones I wanted to
check out as well hey take a seat I'll
be right there
[Music]
was was one of those characters who had
it not look at his shirt what the hell
is going on graphic nature I don't want
to you know judge people but all of them
have like the look like you can look at
a guy I'm like yeah
shot yeah
yeah he likes kids what's going on I
don't know I just was talking to her and
she said come down and visit her I have
a compulsion just to with her younger
women just meeting them I haven't I've
met about a dozen of them online did you
ever get in trouble well I got in
trouble because I met a girl in Michigan
and how old was that girl seven tickets
and you clearly didn't learn your
[ __ ] lesson you gonna tell your folks
about this I was trying to tell my folks
about it you are yes sir how do you
think they're going to react oh I know
my mom's going to take my computer and
completely throw it away
this guy's 48. my mom is gonna take away
my computer
why should you rely on your mommy to do
discipline
here because uh like I said lack of
judgment
right through that door right there
he steps off that backstab which is kind
of a big step and Boom Fort Myers please
right on
rice the audio is a little bit bad on
this one but it's wild and you thought
it was appropriate to walk into the home
of a 14 year old boy who you thought was
alone bucknick
so I think this is one of the very very
earliest they did this this guy just
walks in naked I don't know so what's
your full name
and your school bus driver or a teacher
teacher or a teacher
I'm gonna need to see some ideas
this guy's a [ __ ] teacher turned out
later that he was neither a teacher nor
a bus driver in fact he was unemployed
and had been for some time
okay
what kind of conduct is this for a high
school teacher
you're gonna tell me you've never done
this before minister so you just woke up
this morning
and said I'm going to get involved in
the internet conversation with a 40 year
old boy
I'm gonna go to his house hey who knows
maybe he was on his way to the beach huh
I'm sorry what am I what
what would have happened John if I
wasn't here
so yeah they let him go I don't
understand why he's trying to keep the
towel I guess they weren't working with
the police at this time trying to grab
his clothes and head out the door and he
gets his underwear on and just d-lines
to get out of it if he had just left it
at that you know canelli would have been
a memorable character but what he did
the next day
so literally the next day these are the
12 year old posers nobody has ever gone
through what that man went through when
he got to this house but now this is
just amazing this guy I want to use the
words amazing hello
shirtless holding most of his clothes
and less than 24 hours later there he is
in a chat room trying to make a date
with another young teenage boy he calls
himself special guy amazing the decoy
made a date and they agreed to meet at a
nearby fast food restaurant we move into
position
he walks out of the restaurant and we're
there waiting for I have been in
television for 24 years I'll just come
to get something to eat and I
I'm just getting a McDonald's I was
hungry I just wanted some fries
banana lost for work sir I don't even
know what to ask you first
sir there's a I have the coupon for
chicken my nuggets I get 13 this time
I'm just gonna get something to eat Sean
through this before what are you doing
I've got the chat log again
it's adding up another 13 year old kid
then you're gonna meet him here at
McDonald's you identify yourself you
call yourself shame this time is he
gonna lie again Ask him a series of
personal sexual questions is that
appropriate talk to be having with
someone you think is a 13 year old boy
you know okay he gives up and he just
gets to walk again
[Applause]
shoelaces
and drives off and I'm thinking
I just can't believe yeah how do you let
him go twice Jesus all right let's check
out one more one more did you find the
house okay this is Jeff so cool
I'll take two and a half hours
I don't know just like two and a half
hours this is whatever it's just men
drove across country
yeah all right
oh you're gonna give me a hug no sorry
I'm sorry are you okay yeah I'm okay
I'll settle into it
okay so it kind of get you [ __ ] it's
a small pizza it's like almost as big as
the big one so
I mean obviously they're socially inept
obviously
camera conversation is that that's mom
please is almost as big as a large pizza
so you might as well get the small pizza
Hammer it's just safe for a big piece I
always keep flies
and also who drinks orange juice with
pizza this is almost worse what's next
he's gonna eat it with a knife and four
oh no I just gotta take take something
uh
it's something that I take when I
it's not drugs I think I know what it is
God damn what a pizza we have tonight
who's this
I'll get to that in a minute who are you
who are you you tell me first
you're Jeff right yeah and what are you
doing here tonight Chef hanging out
hanging out with whom
with our who's her
I don't I want to know who you are I
want to know a little bit more about you
first
can I eat first sure go ahead
tell me who you are is you know hey
I didn't know there would be other
people here how do people not recognize
him it's such a big popular show right
didn't have any expectations no
expectations whatsoever no
so you drove two and a half hours sure
did from Boston
who are you no expectations
as a 44 year old guy I shouldn't be
talking to 13 year old girls like this
yet I want to
ugh it just goes back and forth the
whole time like who are you I wait a
little bit I will tell you and then it's
like you're not answering all my
questions I will can you just tell me
who you are I'm Chris Hanson and this is
an investigation called handsome versus
Predator
so if there's anything else you want
people to know anything you want to say
now would be a good time
I can't believe this I was just going to
the beach
I don't wanna I don't want to talk
anymore I can you can leave my camera
wait a minute I can leave and then what
that's not up to me
it's not up to me
he knows he [ __ ] knows
you
'd come here
I don't have anything else to say all
right you can take your pizza if you
like
I'm good thank you very much so the cops
here
you want a slice all right listen I give
you Pizza you get pizza I don't get to
go to jail deal
trade offer
if they're here just bring them in
it'd be best if you went out that way
he doesn't want to get tackled
just out for the garage
so so less satisfying when they're just
like Anyway very interesting if you
enjoyed smash like subscribe see you
guys in the next one